I wasn't sure if the White House knew
about the FBI raid on Trump's Residence
at Mar-A-Lago beforehand I wasn't sure
I'm not sure Biden knows his name half
the time but I was not even sure that
the staffers at the White House who
really run the show over there knew
about the raid
until yesterday when White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean-Pierre said the
White House didn't know about the raid
which convinced me with 100 certainty
that the White House definitely knew
about the raid can you tell us anything
more was he watching the news was he
scrolling Twitter did someone in his
staff flag it for him I can tell you
this he was not aware of of of uh of
of the uh was it the Mar-A-Lago raid I
don't know what you guys are calling it
uh uh before it happened uh I don't know
I don't even know what you guys are
calling it uh I'm a raid uh yeah sorry
never heard that term before Mara what
now Donald who the FB huh sorry not
ringing any bells Move Along Move Along
next question
this woman is such a bad liar if she had
just said yeah we didn't know about that
yeah that was all the FBI on its own
maybe I would have believed her
but to pretend not to have read about
the biggest news story in the country
which pertains to Joe Biden's
predecessor and chief rival in the next
presidential election
to pretend not to know what a raid is
Karine Jean-Pierre was giving off
precisely the same Vibes that Hillary
Clinton did in 2016 when she tried to
play dumb on wiping her email server of
classified material
under the law that decision is made by
the official I was the official I made
those decisions
what like with a cloth or something well
no
I I don't know how it works digitally at
all I do not have any
wipe the server like with a cloth what's
a server what's wiping what's a cloth I
don't know I don't know and she was
obviously guilty as Sin the strategy
didn't work because while Hillary
Clinton is many things she's not dumb
and Joe Biden is another story but even
Biden and his lackeys are not nearly as
dumb as they play what we are seeing
right now is a systemic strategy of
persecuting the ruling party's political
opponents we can say with certainty that
this is not going to stop with Trump and
with the raid on Mar-A-Lago we can say
that because we already we already saw
it play out because less than 24 hours
after the Mar-A-Lago raid the FBI
confiscated the cell phone of the
sitting Republican Congressman good
ranchers is my absolute favorite meat
delivery service and they are on a
mission to donate 100 000 meals to
children in need to help them out I am
offering 10 lucky listeners the chance
to win 30 minutes with me little old me
via zoom on September 30th where you can
ask me anything I hope that the topics
are all just steak and burger related
but you can ask me anything about
anything else you want to all you got to
do is go to goodranchors.com Knowles buy
a box of meat using my code Noel skin
awles you'll get 30 off your order plus
free shipping be automatically entered
to win an invitation to this exclusive
meet and greet get it meet and greet do
you get it hurry hurry up right now the
offer is only valid through August 31st
goodranchers.com Knowles meet and greet
with the fireworks around the Mar-A-Lago
raid people have missed the story that
took place right afterward which in some
ways is is almost more significant one
day after the Mar-A-Lago raid the FBI
confiscated the personal cell phone of
Representative Scott Perry he's a
republican congressman from Pennsylvania
that was while he was traveling on
Tuesday with his family according to
representative Perry this morning while
traveling with my family three FBI
agents visited me and seized my cell
phone they've made no attempt to contact
my lawyer who would have made
arrangements for them to have my phone
if that was their wish I'm outraged
though not surprised that the FBI under
the direction of Merrick Garland's doj
would seize the phone of a sitting
member of Congress this is approaching
the level of a constitutional crisis I'm
not sure that we're quite there yet but
if we're not we're pretty close
the bureaucracy which is now under the
direction of Christopher Ray's doj guy
the doj is one of the executive agencies
under Biden's control is now going after
Republican members of Congress on what
basis we don't really know for sure but
all of the reporting we've seen is that
this has to do with Donald Trump's
attempts to cast doubt on the 2020
presidential election you know the most
secure election ever in human history
where they totally didn't change all the
rules beforehand and where they totally
counted the votes on time and where they
definitely didn't violate the state
constitutions and where they didn't
obviously rig the damn thing you know
that if you have any questions about
that if you cast any doubt on the
election integrity
that we saw in 2020 why you're an
insurrectionist and the the feds have
the right to go in and what sees the
cell phones of sitting members of
Congress
go in and raid the homes of the the home
of the former president and the
presumptive Republican nominee in 2024
I I walk into work today one of my
colleagues greets me says hey how you
doing Michael I say oh it's another fine
day in the Banana Republic we're
descending even further into a Banana
Republic
what is going on here I think a lot of
people
especially the squishes are going to say
oh well yeah this is a little weird it's
a little weird for Biden's FB highly
politicized FBI highly partisan FBI to
go after the opposition party members of
Congress and steal their data and steal
their cell phones it's a little weird to
be raiding the homes of the former
president and the future the presumptive
nominee it's a little weird but okay
it's all right we'll get back to normal
it's totally fine no what we are seeing
play out in real time is a major power
grab and a shift in the way that our
political structure works and that
happens I don't think I'm being
conspiratorial here of course that
happens consider the way our government
looks today with the giant bureaucracy
and the the huge power that the federal
government has over the lives of
ordinary citizens and the pretty much
non-existent power that the states have
vis-a-vis the federal government
consider that and compare that to the
the government we had in the 1790s
or the very early days of the 19th
century or the late days of the 19th
century or the early 20th century it all
looks very very different
the way that the political order looks
changes over time and it changes with
power grabs and it changes with
audacious campaigns and it changes with
Shenanigans and it changes with
illegality and it changes with rigging
elections and it changes with this
branch of government just seizing power
from some other branch of government and
this party just suppressing some other
political party and that stuff really
does happen last night I was sitting out
with a cigar and a drink and I was
reading the constitution of Athens I was
going back from some of my ancient Greek
reading just to try to get out of the
the tumult and the chaos of the modern
news cycle and try to get a little bit
of a broader perspective and when you
just read how the government of Athens
changed over time it's a comedy of
errors it's a parade of villains it's
all sorts of things where people come in
and they say yeah that's the way your
government operated before this is the
way it operates now and you might say
that's unjust and you might not like it
well I don't give a damn because I took
the power
and it that didn't just happen in
ancient Greece that happens in every
single state throughout human history
and it's happening here in the United
States
what we've seen play out over the last
two days is the FBI at the direction of
the doj which has been become highly
partisan and it's clearly at the
direction of the ruling party in the
white house they are saying hey
we're going to do some unprecedented
stuff and we're going to do it you're
going to think it's unjust and you're
going to think it's breaking the norms
and you're going to think that it's a
ruthless power grab
tough what are you gonna do about it and
the answer from the squishes and the
answer from people who are just not
rising to the the call of this present
moment is oh let's just let it play out
nothing to see here move along Move
Along Senator Tim Scott who I like
personal a is a nice guy personally he
just went on CBS and he was asked about
the raid on Mar-A-Lago and he I think he
gave the single worst answer possible
there's been lots of questions before
this raid about whether or not the FBI
is doing their job apolitical and we
don't know the answer to that question
yet this is probably how it's about the
FBI this is going to raise more
questions in my opinion we need to let
this play out and see exactly what
happens but we should all have been
stunned and surprised and shocked at
what happened yesterday the real
question is hey what is the federal
federal records act and and B what are
we talking about it had it has to be
something of incredible magnitude yeah
for at least my side of the aisle to say
that was that was warranted with without
that I think we're going to find
ourselves in a very big mess as it
relates to the credibility of the FBI so
you don't have any concern that they're
going to find anything at the Mar-A-Lago
well I think we should really as opposed
to rushing the Judgment the most
important thing that we can do is let it
play out because I have no idea what
they were looking for I don't think
anybody knows
let it play out
well let it play out
no we do not in fact need to let it play
out we do not need to worry about
rushing to judgment we're not Russian to
judgment
we've seen this play out for six years
now starting with the Russian collusion
hoax we've seen the FBI and the doj
being wielded by the Democrats
specifically against this guy against
Donald Trump to spy on his campaign to
try to stop him from becoming president
to try to oust him when he was president
now to try to stop him from running for
president again I've seen enough we're
not rushing to judgment this is six
years in the making and it's it's so
frustrating to hear Tim Scott say this
because the first part of his answer is
very good he says we're shocked this is
ridiculous this is terrible this is
awful
but let's not do anything about it let's
not do anything let's not even let's not
even
rush to conclusions let's just let's
just let the doj and the FBI and the
Biden White House destroy Donald Trump's
presidential campaign and and wield
arbitrary capricious outrageous power
over their political opponents and
weaponize the federal law enforcement
agencies to to just go after and Destroy
Republicans and then you know once we
see how it plays out then maybe we can
think about doing something then maybe
we can think about fighting back are you
kidding me are you what a what a
worthless answer it's it's even worse
than saying it's not a big deal because
you're saying it is a big deal but we
shouldn't do anything about it come on
come on man come on I sound like Joe
Biden come on man
I'm glad you like that clip now make
sure you ring the bell and subscribe
we've now got over a million subscribers
I'm very grateful for that that's cool
this has become one of the largest
YouTube channels out there but I want it
to be the very largest I want it to be
number one that means I need a billion
subscribers okay and that's going to be
a little bit of a lift but we can do it
make sure send it to your friends bing
bang subscribe ding dong whatever you
got to do we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you